The lead in a show that never saw the light of
day. Starring alongside an Oscar nominee with
hardly anybody noticing. A detour as a half-alien.
Michelle Trachtenberg has some iconic characters
under her belt, but it's been a while since
she's been in anything high-profile. Here's why.
Can you envision Michelle
Trachtenberg starring in Twilight?
She in fact very nearly landed a role
in the popular vampire franchise,
though it ultimately didn't pan out.
As she revealed to Us Weekly in 2011,
"There was definitely interest here and
there because there's only so
few pale girls in Hollywood."
But as it turned out, Trachtenberg had
already signed on to other projects that
conflicted with Twilight, so she
couldn't commit. As she bemoaned,
"I guess schedules never worked out."
Being a part of Twilight would've undoubtedly
lifted Trachtenberg's career to new heights, and
maybe if she'd backed out of another project, she
could've made it happen. Regardless, she tries not
to spend too much time looking back and wondering
how things might've been different. As she put it,
"[Hypothetical answers mean] you're
not living in the moment and you're
looking negatively at what you're doing now."
In 2000, Trachtenberg joined the cast of the
popular supernatural series Buffy the Vampire
Slayer for the show's fifth season. She starred as
Dawn Summers, the title character's little sister,
who proved to be quite pivotal. When
Dawn discovers her true purpose,
she struggles to accept who she is and her
mystical connection to every single dimension
of reality. Trachtenberg was grateful for the
opportunity to be part of such an impactful show,
but she wasn't exactly enthusiastic about
the idea of working on another TV series
once it was over. As she admitted
to Entertainment Weekly in 2004,
"Honestly when I left Buffy, I never thought I'd
go back to TV because I've done it. I'm not a
person to repeat myself creativity-wise.
And I found TV to be rather stifling,
especially Buffy. Three years as one
character — where they're not changing
the character and your abilities aren't being
tested or challenged — gets very repetitive."
While Trachtenberg did eventually return to TV,
her experience of being held back as a
creative individual in front of the camera
may have very well discouraged her from
accepting other small screen roles.
"What? That's so lame."
Perhaps one of the reasons that Michelle
Trachtenberg became so hesitant to accept
certain roles was because some fans of Buffy the
Vampire Slayer responded so negatively to her
character. Critical viewers found Dawn Summers
to be annoying, but to Trachtenberg's credit,
that might just mean that she played the role
of the annoying little sister incredibly well.
Still, comments like that have to hurt. To
this day, Trachtenberg says that people still
tell her about how much they disliked Dawn. As
she recounted to Entertainment Weekly in 2017,
"I still get comments like, 'Oh my God! I think
Dawn is so annoying!' I get it. It's fine. [...] I
rarely get the, 'Oh, she ruined the show.' I
do get a lot of, 'Oh, she was so whiny!' Hi,
were you a teenager? Oh, you were docile, sitting
in the corner, doe-eyed and happy to be there?
No. There's a reason why teenagers have a
stigma, and that is what Joss [Whedon] wrote."
It may be true that Dawn was
prone to sulking and complaining,
but as Trachtenberg notes, she was
at least a realistic character.
"What I respect is the fans."
Trachtenberg had a recurring role as Georgina
Sparks on The CW teen drama Gossip Girl from 2008
to 2012, and in the midst of that, she had her
sights set on starring on her very own TV show.
In 2010, Vulture reported that the production team
behind Gossip Girl was working on producing a new
CW drama for Trachtenberg. She was set to star
as a criminology student with a complicated past
and an uncanny talent for profiling
suspects. The actor had pitched the
idea for the show herself, and she
was also set to serve as a producer.
Originally, the show was supposed to begin airing
with hour-long episodes in the fall of 2011.
This would've represented a big step forward in
Trachtenberg's career. But like so many other
interesting series that never see the light of
day, the pilot was simply never picked up. Losing
the opportunity to produce and star in her own TV
show was definitely a setback for Trachtenberg.
So why haven't Michelle Trachtenberg's more
recent films gotten the same attention as some
of her earlier projects? Well,
after her time on Gossip Girl,
her subsequent projects simply haven't
earned very many positive reviews.
In 2014, Trachtenberg appeared in
the sci-fi thriller The Scribbler,
which told the story of a woman who attempts to
eliminate her multiple personalities through a
risky experimental process. But this comic book
adaptation fell flat among critics and audiences.
That same year, Trachtenberg also starred in the
made-for-TV comedy movie Save the Date as a woman
who races to find a husband after having a few
too many drinks and booking a wedding venue.
With middling reviews, Save the Date wasn't
exactly a boon for Trachtenberg's career either.
Then in 2015's The Christmas Gift, she
played a curious reporter who tries to
track down a stranger who unknowingly changed
her life after sending an anonymous present.
Unfortunately, The Christmas Gift didn't make
much of an impression on critics either, so for
a couple of years, it seemed like Trachtenberg was
struggling to find roles that truly suited her.
In 2015, Trachtenberg took on a starring role
on the web series Guidance, which was hosted
on Verizon's mobile video streaming platform go90.
She played Anna, a guidance counselor who tries to
help one of her students investigate the source
of some scandalous photos. She only appeared in
the first season, as each season featured a new
cast of characters dealing with different issues.
Ultimately, Guidance was canceled after three
seasons. The short episodes just didn't pack
enough punch into a few minutes, and critics
and audiences felt relatively neutral about
the whole thing. The streaming platform
it was hosted on ended up folding as well,
as there just wasn't enough interest in what go90
had to offer. While the premise of the series
was interesting, most people simply weren't
checking out go90 for any reason whatsoever.
"Stickers?"
"She was big into scrapbooking."
"Who isn't?"
"I love to scrap."
In 2016, Trachtenberg starred as Dallas Baxter
in the Lifetime movie Sister Cities. Based on the
2006 play of the same name by Colette Freedman,
the plot follows Dallas and her three sisters,
who've been estranged for years until their
mother's sudden death brings them back together.
"Dallas is, is very type A and very particular.
Um, she's a complete perfectionist."
The sisters then must untangle their past
and investigate the strange circumstances
surrounding their mom's death. The result is a
family mystery and a family drama all in one,
making for a suspenseful narrative, although
it didn't make much of a cultural footprint.
Sister Cities actually did earn a positive
response from audiences, but it wasn't like
critics were talking about it nonstop. Those that
did take note of the film generally enjoyed it,
and it surely helped that it had an Oscar
nominee in its cast in the form of Jacki
Weaver as the mother. Perhaps it flew under the
radar simply because it was a made-for-TV movie,
but whatever the reason, it didn't
do much for Trachtenberg's career.
Trachtenberg has always been
passionate about acting,
but that doesn't mean she's not
also interested in other showbiz
roles. And as it turns out, she's actually
written several screenplays. It's only natural
that the actor who made a name for herself
as an aspiring writer in Harriet the Spy
would be interested in penning her own stories.
As she revealed to Entertainment Weekly in 2017,
"I'm fully WGA and a writer
and have sold several projects.
I feel like [I'm living] a Hollywood
version of Harriet's life."
At the time, she was working on two writing
projects that she was particularly passionate
about. One was a period piece based on a true
story taking place over 30 years beginning in
the 1950s. The other one told the story of an
accessories editor with aspirations of being
a writer. Alas, these screenplays never made
it to the screen. Perhaps Trachtenberg is now
writing something else, or maybe she's
pushed these plans to the backburner.
In 2018, Trachtenberg lent her voice to the
Facebook web series Human Kind Of. She played
Judy Reilly, an awkward teenager who discovers
the unexpected reason she's always felt so out
of place, as it turns out that her estranged
father is actually an extraterrestrial.
Judy has no idea how she's going
to navigate life as a half-human,
half-alien teenager, and it's not as if
high school wasn't hard enough already.
But her optimistic mother and her best friend
have her back, and as the series progresses,
she learns to embrace both sides of her
personality and everything that makes her unique.
Each episode ran about five minutes,
making for an easy and entertaining watch.
The series earned decent
reviews, but unfortunately,
it would be another short-lived project for
Trachtenberg, as it lasted for only a single
season. While Trachtenberg has definitely
shown her willingness to think outside the
box by taking on projects like this, it hasn't
necessarily translated to mainstream attention.
"You have a clot of explaining to do."
"Mom, don't do that."
Trachtenberg had a memorable recurring role
on the original TV version of Gossip Girl.
Georgina Sparks stirred up trouble every
time she came back to New York City and was
one of those classic characters who viewers
loved to hate. She was simply captivating,
and whenever she turned up, you knew
that everything was about to go haywire.
Trachtenberg has yet to appear on the Gossip
Girl reboot that premiered on HBO Max in 2021,
but that may soon change. According to Josh
Schwartz, who was one of the showrunners
during Gossip Girl's original run and is
also an executive producer for the reboot,
the production team told the original cast
members that they were welcome to come back
for the reboot. But so far, most of them haven't
taken him up on the offer. That is, except for
Kristen Bell as the voice of Gossip Girl, as well
as a few other supporting characters. As Schwartz
explained to reporters during the Television
Critics Association summer press tour in 2019,
"We've reached out to all of them to let them know
it was happening, and we'd love for them to be
involved if they want to be involved but certainly
didn't want to make it contingent upon [them being
involved]. They played these characters
for six years, and if they felt like they
were good with that, we want to respect that, but
obviously... it would be great to see them again."
After wrapping up Human Kind Of, it seemed
like Trachtenberg went on a bit of a hiatus
for a while. For a few years, she didn't appear on
screen at all, and her upcoming slate doesn't look
terribly busy. However, she has spent some time
teasing a new project that she'd been working
on behind the scenes, and early in 2021, she
revealed just what she'd been waiting to unveil:
a true crime show. She excitedly shared the news
with her fans on Instagram, as she announced,
"The cat's out of the bag. Excited to share
that soon, you can watch me as the host and
executive producer of my new true crime show
Meet, Marry, Murder. Do you really know the
person you go to sleep with every night?
Stay tuned.....it's going to be killer."
"Be careful who you sleep with at night."
Trachtenberg has been a fan of true crime for
a while. She even wrote a screenplay about a
serial killer years ago. So clearly, this
show must be a major accomplishment for her.
Meet, Marry, Murder Season 1 aired on Tubi in
2021, so maybe it won't be long before we stop
thinking of Michelle Trachtenberg as a mere relic
of the early and mid-2000s. Hollywood may have
seemingly lost interest in her for a while, but it
sounds like she's not quite done with Hollywood.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite actors are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.